am 28 februar werden in enns in
oberösterreich insgesamt 745 soldatinnen
und soldaten nach erfolgreichem
abschluss der heeres unteroffiziers
akademie kurz fuhr genannt mit ihrem
neuen dienstgrad wachtmeister
ausgemustert es ist ein tag der freude
und ein großer erfolg für das
österreichische bundesheer dass heute
mehr als 700 junge berufs und miliz und
offiziere zur ausmusterung von uns
angetreten sind
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
die erstmals eine ausmusterung bei wohnt
freut sich nicht nur über 745 neue
wachtmeister sondern auch über die
jahrgangsbeste deshalb freut es mich
heute umso mehr dass ich bei dieser für
mich ersten ausmusterung dabei sein kann
und auch ein wachtmeister zu
jahrgangsbesten gratulieren durfte als
jahrgangsbeste überreicht
verteidigungsministerin tanna der
steirerin katharina holzinger den
goldenen ring der harris unteroffiziers
akademie für herausragende leistungen
etwas zu begreifen kann oft wenn die
wissenschaft anmuten aber etwas zu
vermitteln ist immer eine kunst und wir
sind der kunst so ist gibt es keine
richtigen und falschen antworten sondern
verschiedene wege und möglichkeiten zu
einem zufriedenstellenden ziel zu kommen
das ziel der ausmusterung haben alles
745 neue wachtmeister mit diesem festakt
erreicht und die jahrgangsbeste fühlt
sich zusätzlich geehrt es ist eine ehre
die nicht nur mir zuteil wird es ist
eine ehre die natürlich auch eine ganze
klasse meinen ganzen lehrgang trifft und
natürlich eine ehre die auf meine
kameraden teilen und meine leer und
offizieren natürlich auch bei
klassenleiter und selbstständig auch
meine einheit zu hause